you know things are bad when Biden's
media minions stop covering up for
Hunter the New York Times exposing the
first Sons failed plea deal turns out
that the U.S attorney turned special
counsel David Weiss planned to let
Hunter off without charges for tax
evasion that was until IRS
whistleblowers forced him to change his
mind and Politico reporting that
Hunter's lawyer threatened doj
prosecutors with putting Papa Joe on the
witness stand the move worked leading to
Hunter's bogus sweetheart plea deal and
the Washington Post raising questions
about how the special counsel apparently
worked with Joe's other son Beau even
CNN is calling out Joe Biden's Bluff
I mean Trump was right I mean he did
make a fortune from China and Joe Biden
was wrong I don't know that he was lying
about it he might not have been told by
Hunter but this blind spot is a problem
I think Biden has basically got three
issues where he's not figured out what
to say okay one is obviously the
question's about Hunter Biden his son
the other is what to say about the
investigation to Donald Trump and the
third is about his age those are three
massive issues that are sort of clouding
his re-election campaign
Poor Man's five am I right they need a
bigger table that's embarrassing they're
all crammed in there like it's
Thanksgiving on their little card table
and the adults are somewhere else data
two parts to this this is amazing the
Jake Tapper thing like so obviously CNN
is getting the go-ahead to slide to
slowly remove uh Biden from the
presidency because they they never said
this before now Jake's saying it but
then he offered that little that little
get out of jail free card by saying
what's his blind spot it's not a blind
spot he actually sees it it's like a
glaring neon sign and what's interesting
too is that
it wasn't just CNN but many others took
that National Security letter that 51
National Security folks signed saying
that the hunter Biden laptop was
disinformation a lot of reporters went
with that I don't know if they're mad at
those sources if they're frustrated with
those words like I would be so what
would be different going into the next
election if now you believe that Trump
was right at the time so what would you
do differently next time that would be
interesting the part of the story I'm
very much interested in is that
apparently David Weiss was not going to
charge Hunter Biden with anything at all
until he heard that the whistleblowers
were going to come forward and now some
Democrats want to prosecute the
whistleblowers yes for bringing it up so
that there is whistleblower protection
for a reason and I know that on both
sides people love or hate The
Whistleblower depending on who it is in
this particular case I don't think
anyone's really put a dent into the
reputations of shapley or Ziegler and
oops they did it again is it a situation
with the media when it comes to the
story oh that's a nice little thing we
can put in there for Britney Spears
thing I'm gonna make a little more sip
around here yes as you know I hate
people who whistle Jesse so we'll move
on to you this is a great point this
plea deal we were all trying to figure
out why this happened
and that's pretty ballsy to say we're
going to put your dad on the uh on on
the stage and then Weiss fell for the
bluff yeah you really think Joe Biden's
gonna take the stand at trial this was
never going to trial anyway so I mean
this guy Joe Biden himself said all
politics is personal so you got to
wonder who this guy was is why he's been
living in Delaware a little fiefdom for
25 years as a prosecutor it's like where
you live Upstate Greg everybody kisses
your butt you know everybody and you do
everybody favor that is true he actually
gave Joe a pass when he had these straw
donors in 2008. some guy volunteered to
wear a wire to bust him and they said uh
go chase off then he worked with Beau
Biden and then he had all of his minions
that were running this investigation or
running it into the ground giving Hunter
a tip off saying oh here he comes up
those search warrant for you they were
blocked at every pass now how can Jake
Tapper play dumb for this long I had no
offense to Jake but you can't say that
Joe Biden had no idea Hunter got paid
Millions from China okay you flew your
son to China and then he's filthy rich
you can't add that up you were getting
an office with his Chinese business
partner named dong that never rang a
bell oh when you were writing this guy a
letter to get his daughter into Brown
University the chairman you never asked
why this was happening come on Jake
you're better than that maybe you're not
um judge it's interesting the timing
don't you think now admitting this is
happening the timing tells the whole
story and David Weiss has to go he is
corrupt he has proven himself to not be
trustworthy he has destroyed the
American people's faith in the criminal
justice system uh he had no intention of
filing charges which is why he continued
to allow and continues to allow as we
speak the statute of limitations to run
you know this Chris Clark uh he was a
smart cookie what he did was he went
over Weiss's head with the threat to
call uh Joe Biden as a fact witness why
because he knows Weiss was not the guy
making the decisions so anyone would say
what are you going to call him is a fact
witness to the gun I mean Joe Biden has
a policy against gun what's he got to
say you're going to call him as a
reputation witness to say my son has a
stellar reputation in the community or
are you going to call him as a fact
witness a tax evasion so he's going to
say yeah I took some of the cash of
course they were never going to call him
and the fact that they threatened them
with that and they were ready to go with
it and just not drop it all is really
stunning to me it was never going to
happen it was a threat and it was
nothing more than that but the outcome
with the whistleblowers and now today we
find out if you recall there was a
conversation between Weiss and six other
people shapley recorded that
conversation documented it
contemporaneously making it a business
record that wise said I do not make the
calls in this case four people have been
subpoenaed today two of them are sacs
special agents in charge one of the IRS
one of the FBI the other is a director
of field operation IRS and the other is
the uh uh assistant Sac they will now
corroborate the David Weiss admitted to
everyone that he didn't have the final
say now what's the justice department
going to do Merrick Garland and this guy
wise are dirty they corrupt and they
have to go you know Harold you can't
spell Delaware without aware
anyway can we show that table again
look I'm not going to speak to the
motivation and biases of these people
but I'll say this I think the process I
differ with us around the table a little
bit I think the process has worked for
this regard
um whatever their motivations may have
been and a lot of times the the process
is designed as the judge knows to
protect uh and to ensure that their
checks and balances so if you assume the
worst case about wise which I don't if
indeed and again I think the New York
Times can sometimes engage as as
president Trump often says in fake news
we're taking their reporting to be
actually what happened here but and I'll
assume that for a moment but let's
assume weyson want to bring it there
were whistleblowers that came forward
and that process worked those
whistleblowers were protected they were
able to share uh their thoughts and they
were they're protected in the process
three uh Mr Weiss they were blocked from
investigating the big guy no but they
were able to whistleblow which means we
as the Americans that's after the fact
but Jess let me just finish my point
whatever the mo well that's the whole
point of a whistleblower are you able
you you during it or after that I had to
have blown the whistle Harold so the
special counsel Mr wayson decides that
he needs the powers of a special counsel
to ensure that he can go above and
beyond Mr Garland for that matter this
isn't any justice department it's not
just this justice department any justice
department that is the case you now have
Weiss who's a special counsel after five
years as a U.S attorney he now has the
opportunity to open investigations in
California which he has to open an
investigation in DC but he already had
that right he lied that's the whole
point I know he did not have that right
he didn't so why did he lie well he
never said that you're going to set it
right in the meeting where we are now
the pro the judge in this case did her
role she came forward and said let me
protect the defendant and ask everyone
do you know what's in this agreement and
you know what there was no meaning of
the minds so we are where we are again
I'm not going to get into the
motivations and biases you could be
right and I certainly could be right but
who knows as always you are right now
you have this special counsel and I can
assure you there's no one at the White
House I don't I'm not speaking because
I've spoken to them I cannot imagine
anyone at the White House is glad that
the special counsel said that I cannot
give you assurances that President Biden
is not being investigated here that says
to me the process is working who's the
special counsel David Weiss oh can I see
the table the table of that other crew
we see the table I just want to show you
their
oh never mind they can't get it oh well
it's Monday we'll wait got nothing else
to do so how was your weekend it was
pretty good you went to the Bahamas it
was good yeah excellent yeah it was fine
I had a flat tire oh wow yeah terrible
did you change it yourself no
no why did its former press secretary
conservatives it's funny
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now